when we talk about Hinduism or sanatana
Dharma the focus is usually on the
so-called Vedic or brahmanical tradition
that incredibly complex web of beliefs
and practices related to the ancient
Vedic texts and the philosophies that
are based on those texts such as vedanta
for example which we have talked about
at length previously on this channel
even I in my video on The Vedas said
that this group of texts is the one
unifying factor in the large category
that we call Hinduism today which
actually isn't entirely true indeed
there exists and have existed other
Traditions that still fall under the
umbrella of Hinduism that didn't grow
out of The Vedic tradition they are of
course still for the most part in
conversation with The Vedas and The
Vedic tradition but not as their primary
source we already talked about one such
tradition Tantra in a previous episode
and today we're going to continue in a
similar line because one of the most
significant and yet surprisingly less
known forms of Indian religion and
philosophy has been the non-dual school
called Kashmir shaivism
a school where the god Shiva is
worshiped as the one reality and
consciousness of all things and whose
main foundational figure abhinava Gupta
is one of the greatest and most
impressive philosophers in history
[Music]
in terms of non-dualistic schools of
Hinduism a Dwight the vedanta is
definitely the most famous around the
world but a serious rival has always
been Kashmir shaivism often also called
tarika shaibism it is also a strongly
non-dual and monistic tradition but with
a focus on Shiva rather than Vishnu and
with some significant differences in
terms of metaphysics Kashmir shaivism
shouldn't necessarily be seen as a fixed
school it is in fact more of a name for
a complex group of related non-dual
thinkers and philosophies in the shivai
tradition in and around Kashmir it's
thus hard to pinpoint An Origin or
founder as such but the most Central and
maybe foundational figure is the amazing
philosopher and Mystic abhinava Gupta
who is often said to have brought
together the complex array of different
philosophies and religious Traditions at
the time into a unified system that we
know as Kashmir shaivism abhinava Gupta
is really one of the most significant
figures in Indian history and it's
strange and a little sad that he isn't
more well known and appreciated his
writing span a vast amount of subjects
from metaphysics and tantric practices
scriptural commentary and even
Aesthetics but before we start exploring
him further let's back up a little bit
first what are the basics of what we're
discussing here
Kashmir shaivism is as the name suggests
a form of shaivism
so what is shaivism then shavism is a
name to denote a vast group of religious
traditions in India that worship the god
Shiva as the primary deity this is in
opposition to for example vaishnavism
which are Traditions that worship Vishnu
as the primary deity and all the schools
we've discussed so far primarily the
different schools of vedanta associated
with ramanuja mava and to some degree
shankara are more so a part of the
vaishnavai tradition so shaivism is the
worship of Shiva and from there the
topic branches out into a web of many
different schools and tendencies only if
one of which is Kashmir shaivism not
whereas the vaishnavi tradition is often
based primarily on The Vedas upanishads
and works like the famous bhagavad-gita
the Shiva tradition has some different
Origins even though drawing a clear line
like this should be avoided the earliest
known forms of sectarian shaibism appear
in the first few centuries CE or A.D
around the second to third century
at this point we have groups like The
pashupatas and the siddhanta shivaites
both shivai Traditions that focus on
worship of Shiva with the aim of
becoming United with him
at the same time these early forms of
shaivism are dualistic in nature that is
they conceive of a clear ontological
difference between Shiva as the Lord
Pati and the human being and the created
World it isn't until later that we see
the development of a more non-dualistic
strand within this tradition the main
textual sources for most of the Shiva
tradition are the so-called agamas a
vast collection of texts that were
commented on by people like abhinava
Gupta later on
so this is one aspect of this
development the emergence of the agamic
text and a devotional tradition
dedicated to Shiva in particular at the
same time we also see the emergence of
the tradition known as Tantra with its
own text which went under the same name
that is Tantra
this was a tradition that put an
emphasis on esotericism spiritual
practice and the body and senses as
important vessels for enlightenment
sometimes even using erotic imagery the
tantric strand was easily harmonized
with the shivite schools and indeed
developed in tandem with them the two
basically influencing each other
we have dedicated a full episode to
Tantra in particular if you want to know
more about that topic but Tantra also
became Central to another important
aspect of the larger shy by tradition
namely shaktism or the worship of the
goddess or female aspect of the Divine
often called Shakti it's already getting
a little complicated but bear with me so
there are schools of devotional shaivism
dualistic schools of shaivism there are
developing in tandem where in connection
with other schools or movements like
tantrism and shaktism but the first
example of a properly non-dualistic
shaibism comes in this scripture called
the Shiva sutras a collection of
aphorisms thought to have been revealed
to the 9th century Sage vasugupta Legend
says that he had a dream where Shiva
told him to go to a certain rock on
which the sutras were inscribed
this is thus considered to be the words
of Shiva himself in a way and as the
foundational text or texts for non-dual
Kashmir shaibism
vasugupta may have been a historical
figure and tradition says that he had
two students kalata and somananda the
former figure kalata is often thought to
be the author of another foundational
text the spandakarika the treat is on
vibration which talks about the Ultimate
Reality of Consciousness as vibration or
spanda
an essential vibration that is at the
core of reality and which can be used to
reach Enlightenment this is another key
aspect of non-dual shaivism at the time
that second student somananda originated
another significant tradition namely the
philosophical School of recognition
called pratya bijna in Sanskrit this
school is perhaps best represented by
his student with paladeva and proposes
that everything is one with the absolute
unified Consciousness that is Shiva and
that humans can reach Liberation by
recognizing their own fundamental
reality as that very consciousness
as we saw aside from these philosophical
development the tantric systems had also
developed into a significant force in
particular these schools known as kawla
or kramakala with a focus on worship of
the goddess or Shakti in the form of
Kali as well as what is known as the
tarika lineage with focus on three
Divine energies would become important
for Kashmir shaivism it should be
pointed out that while we've been
talking about these as different schools
or movements we should be very careful
not to draw two Stark borders between
them because they've always been very
strongly interrelated and and and
connected to each other right the the
borders between them aren't clear at all
but it can be helpful to look at it from
this basic perspective to get a better
grasp of the overall development of this
tradition but it can be a little
difficult to grasp how this all fits
together and in what way even for myself
if I'm being honest the primary master
of Kashmir shaivism in the 20th century
lakshman Joe formulated it in this way
tarika is the overarching term and
pratya bijna kawla Karama and spanda all
fit under this category as sub-systems
quote the tarika system is comprised of
four subsystems the pratya bijna system
the kawla system the Kramer system and
the spanda system
these four systems which form the one
thought of the trica system all accept
and are based on the same scriptures
because it is here that abhinava Gupta
enters the scene and starts a project of
basically synthesizing all of these
related schools and movements into a
coherent and very impressive system
abhinava Gupta was probably born
sometime around 950 to 975 A.D in the
region of Kashmir he came from a
brahmana family and clearly had a
passion for learning as he basically
started studying every subject
imaginable
he would have studied scriptures like
the agamas and the tantras and the Shiva
tradition as a whole as well as the
traditional Vedic literature he studied
all the so-called schools of Hindu
philosophy or the darshanas like sankya
vedanta nyaya and judging from his text
he had a Mastery of all these topics it
seems that he even studied non-hindu
religions like Buddhism and Jainism and
had an impressively comprehensive grasp
of these topics as well
he also studied things like philosophy
of language drama music and Aesthetics
all topics that he would write important
Works about this also came with a
spiritual vocation and it was soon also
initiated into the tantric traditions of
kawla and Karama under teachers like
shambunata who was his main Guru and
belonged to the kawala lineage as well
as putiraja and many other gurus he said
to have reached spiritual illumination
or Enlightenment through these tantric
practices
he was taught not only these spiritual
practices of Tantra and goddess worship
but also the philosophy of recognition
and the spanda school that we mentioned
earlier in other words abhinava Gupta
was an incredibly learned and
accomplished person he was a scholar and
polymath able to intellectually tackle a
vast amount of different subjects as
well as an enlightened Guru involved in
spiritual practices and teaching his own
students this path to realization at the
same time he wasn't a renunciating monk
who lived alone in the woods or
something he lived with his family and
stayed active as a teacher and friend
all of which is connected to the ideas
of Tantra and shaivism and its emphasis
on living in the world rather than
detached from it a topic that we'll
return to later he seems to have been
quite the character as descriptions from
that time attest to quote abhinava Gupta
has his eyes trembling in ecstasy in the
middle of his forehead is a conspicuous
tilaka made of Ashes he has
hanging from his ear his long hair is
held by a Garland of flowers he has a
long beard and golden skin his neck is
dark with a shining yaksha Panka powder
his upavita string is hanging down loose
from his neck he wears a silken cloth as
white as Moonbeams and he sits in the
yogic position known as virashana
one hand is held on his knee holding a
rosary with his fingers clearly making
the sign that signifies his knowledge of
the highest Shiva he plays on his
resonating loot with the tips of his
quivering fingers of his lotus-like left
hand
all of this learning and spiritual
practice allowed his genius to shine
through in his many writings in works
like the Tantra loka his largest and
most significant philosophical
theological work he explicates a system
that expertly brings together all the
strands of thought at the time into a
unified Hall
from the devotional shy my tradition to
the philosophies of the Shiva sutras the
philosophy of recognition and spanda the
tantric schools of kawla Karama and
trika as well as many other areas of
knowledge it's all harmonized in an
incredibly impressive way in the
writings of abhinava Gupta those who
study his texts are met with the density
and difficulty in his writings and it
really requires you to have an almost
equally broad knowledge of all the Hindu
schools of philosophy and scriptures to
fully appreciate and understand what he
is trying to do
the Tantra loka has never been
translated into English sadly but that
isn't his only text he wrote the Tantra
Sara as a kind of summary of the former
work as well as devotional hymns
commentaries on scriptures and
independent philosophical treatises
for example even though he was a shy
bite abhinava Gupta wrote a famous
commentary on the bhagavad-gita which is
of course a primarily vaishnavai text
with the god Krishna at its Center in
the fields of arts and Aesthetics he
also wrote a word called abina babarati
a commentary on the natya shastra by
barata Muni which tackles topics related
to the Performing Arts and the theory of
rasa at the center of any aesthetic
experience of art this has become one of
the most important and influential works
on this topic of Aesthetics in the
history of India and it kind of deserves
a topic or an episode of its own
actually
and it really shows you the the breadth
and ingenious arabinava Gupta that even
though he's primarily famous for his his
writings in the Kashmir Shiva tradition
he's also one of the most influential
writers on Aesthetics in in Indian
history he was that much of a polymath
and a broad thinker in that regard in
shorts abhinava Gupta was quite a genius
who had a mass passive impact on Indian
intellectual history
and most importantly for our discussion
today he is the most Central and
foundational figure in what we call
Kashmir shaivism
as we saw he took a bunch of schools and
lineages and unified them into this
incredible philosophy which he himself
often called simply trica which we which
is where we get the name tarika shaivism
the reason that is most often called
Kashmir shaibism in the west is simply
because abhinava Gupta and all the other
non-dualistic thinkers were mentioned
mostly lived in Kashmir and the school
has been associated with that region
ever since then in a sense all of what
were talked about so far fall under the
category of Kashmir shaivism it's a name
for the non-dual forms of shaivism that
flourished in Kashmir at this time and
which was primarily systematized into
the form we know it today in the
writings of abhinava Gupta so now we
thus get to that very difficult part
where we're supposed to somehow Define
or summarize what Kashmir shaivism is
all about so what does this tradition
teach
well first of all and this is often the
case with things like this Kashmir
shaivism isn't just a quote-unquote
philosophy in the modern sense of that
word it does include doctrinal
speculation about metaphysical realities
and such things for sure but a
significant aspect of this tradition is
its participatory and practical aspect
it is a spiritual tradition in the
Tantra lineage that emphasizes practices
like meditation mantras asceticism and
other spiritual practices with the aim
of reaching Liberation through knowledge
of One's Own Unity with Shiva or with
absolute Consciousness so this should be
kept in mind throughout and I will try
my best to include these practical
aspects even though they are a lot
harder to talk about for various reasons
but if we focus more on the theoretical
aspects of this tradition what does it
say about reality and our place in it
the basic principle of Kashmir shaibism
is a strict non-dualism there is only
one unified reality the Supreme
Consciousness which is identical with
Shiva
Shiva is everything and thus everything
consists of and takes place within that
one consciousness
I could also put it this way all that is
is consciousness a single absolute
Consciousness in which everything takes
place and which everything is
Consciousness is identical to being
itself or existence to exist means to be
Consciousness to be experienced by an
awareness that is identical to yourself
that Consciousness the absolute itself
the real is represented by and is
identical to the god Shiva
so Shiva is being and the reality of all
things there is only Shiva in other
words this is a non-dualistic and
monistic theology or philosophy
but there are also a lot of complexities
to this system of thought which we will
have to dive deeper into now you
probably know that I'm usually not too
fond of comparisons but it might be
helpful in this case to look at the
other major and most famous
non-dualistic School of Hinduism advice
and see where the two diverge because
there are indeed a few significant
differences between them a Dwight
davidanta and its Representatives like
shankara talks about the absolutes as
Brahman which in some schools is
identified with Vishnu but in the more
strictly non-dualistic advaita is
usually seen as an attribute less
reality
the Kashmir shy bites also talk about
Brahman occasionally and it is clear
that they see their concept of Shiva as
identical to Brahman but they prefer to
use the more personal Divine form of
Shiva as the embodiment of the real and
use many different names for it such as
well Shiva bhairava para meshwara the
Supreme Lord and similar words the
reason for this emphasis on the more
personal form of the Divinity will
become clear later on in the discussion
the two schools are indeed similar in
that they conceive of the world in
non-dualist terms there is only the
absolutes and nothing other than it has
self-existence
but they also conceive of this
non-dualism in significantly different
ways
in advaita vedanta there is only the one
Brahman and everything else is a kind of
Illusion Brahman is one and absolute an
unchanging essence of reality
this means that all multiplicity we
experience hence everything we
experience as other than Brahman quote
unquote is unreal in a sense it's the
result of what's known as Avidia or
ignorance and Maya illusion we falsely
see all these things in the world and
superimpose self-existence and identity
upon them but in reality none of it's
real because it's all the Brahman
now it needs to be said that this is not
some kind of existential nihilism in
fact writers like shankara argue
precisely in opposition to nihilism
they aren't saying that nothing is real
as such but that everything is simply
the one Brahman and everything we
experience as other than Brahman is
false insofar as it is other than
Brahman just like the person in the
famous analogy falsely thinks that he
sees a snake on the road when in reality
it's only a rope so we should realize
the illusory nature of the world but not
in the sense that there is nothing there
at all only insofar as we see a snake
when in reality it's just a rope when we
realize what is real the snake doesn't
disappear into nothingness instead we
just see it and but for what it truly is
which is a rope
similarly the world is real insofar as
it is Brahman but unreal insofar as it
is seen as other than Brahman in its
multiplicity this means that advaita
vedanta emphasizes a kind of turning
away from the world the world as we know
it is unreal and we are to transcend
this world to reach the one Brahman
which is our true identity once we look
past the world
aduaita is a negating non-dualism in
other words Brahman is alone one and
unchanging and to reach it we must
negate everything else which is illusory
this is not the approach of the Kashmir
shivites they agree that the absolute in
this case Shiva is all that there is and
nothing exists apart from him but their
view of the relationship between the
absolutes and our everyday world of
experience and multiplicity is
fundamentally different The World Is Not
An Illusion at all multiplicity is not
unreal it's a real manifestation of the
Oneness of Shiva
in other words it's a philosophy of
affirmation everything is Shiva
including multiplicity and every aspect
of the world as we experience it Shiva
or Supreme Consciousness is one for sure
but he's also multiplicity and one does
not cancel out the other
in fact in order for Shiva to be
absolute in order to uphold a true
non-dualism or monism it must somehow
unify Oneness and diversity as a single
identical thing
writes quote
we do not base our contention that
reality is won because of the
contradictions inherent in saying that
it is dual it is your approach that
accepts this method well if Duality and
Oneness were in fact to contradict each
other they would clearly be two distinct
realities
in other words if Oneness and Duality
were truly two different things where
Duality is false and Oneness is real as
the advaitan would say that very
statement implies Duality because the
conceives of two opposing Concepts
different from each other the shy bites
like abhinava Gupta instead affirm that
Oneness and Duality or diversity is one
and the same thing it's all encompassed
by the reality of Shiva the eminent
scholar Mark deshkovsky says quote the
Shiva method is one of an Ever widening
inclusion of phenomena mistakingly
thought to be outside the absolute the
vedanta on the other hand seeks to
understand the nature of the absolute by
excluding every element of experience
which does not conform to the Criterion
of absoluteness until All That Remains
is the unqualified Brahman the shaivas
approach is one of affirmation and the
vedantans one of negation they arrive at
the absolute from opposite directions
this approach of the shivaites is not
only important on a philosophical level
but it also has significant impact on
the Practical aspects of the tradition
which we'll see later in this way and
many others the Shiva of Kashmir
shaivism is significantly more Dynamic
and kind of In Motion than the static
and unchanging Brahman of vedanta
Shiva is a personal God he is the
Supreme Consciousness and being which
include the dynamic aspects of manifest
reality
he is a reality which pulsates and
vibrates it's a Consciousness that knows
itself in a dynamic self-knowing that
manifests the universe precisely as the
content of that self-knowing
indeed in this sense Shiva is often seen
as having two quote-unquote aspects
aspects which are still part of the same
one consciousness
the fullness of Consciousness include
what is known as prakasha the Divine
Lights Of Consciousness this is Shiva as
he is in his eternal self the pure
essence of the Supreme Lord
quote prakasha is the pure Luminosity or
self-showing that constitutes the
essence and ultimate identity Atma of
phenomena
that things appear at all is due to the
Lights Of Consciousness and their
appearing is itself this light which
bestows on all things their evidence
manifest nature
secondly there is vimarsha which is the
reflective Consciousness that Sheba has
of himself
Shiva as Consciousness and similarly to
the news of titanus and neoplatonism is
simultaneously awareness being aware of
itself through an awareness that is
identical to itself
the Supreme Lord includes an aspect that
reflects upon itself
Consciousness is conscious of itself and
this reflective awareness is vimasha
this second aspect of the Supreme is
also identified with Shakti the goddess
or divine feminine to the masculine
Shiva in other words the absolute itself
and thus reality as a whole is in a
sense a dynamic Union and separation
between feminine and masculine Shiva and
Shakti often represented as a kind of
sexual act where awareness reflects upon
itself in a kind of pulsation or
vibration that lies at the core of
reality indeed this idea is Central to
the very conception of creation and the
nature of the universe why does Shiva
create the universe to use abrahamic
language how does the one absolute
Supreme Lord go from his inherent state
to the world of Multiplicity where does
all this come from
as we saw the vedanton would basically
say that it doesn't the world of
Multiplicity is an illusion it is Maya
if anything it is the play or Leela of
God that manifests the false sense of
diversity and Duality which pervades the
universe and which ultimately we must
transcend to reach Brahman
the shivites have a rather different
idea to them it is this very Dynamic
aspect of the Supreme self that results
in the manifestation of the world of
diversity
there is a huge emphasis put on the
concept of the freedom of Shiva the
svatantria
Shiva is absolutely free and acts
according to his Free Will and it is
this freedom and will that results in
the creation of the world
as we saw Shiva is both the absolute
Transcendent self for Consciousness the
utmost unchanging light of subjectivity
itself but that Consciousness also
contemplates itself right it looks back
at itself which creates a kind of
artificial kind of duality
it must right there's the person who
who's contemplating and the thing that
is contemplated so when Shiva
contemplates himself that creates this
kind of artificial Duality between the
contemplator and the contemplated but in
reality they are of course one on the
same thing here we have Shiva as the
light of Consciousness and Shakti the
divine feminine as the self-reflexive
aspect of that Consciousness which
becomes the active power of Shiva to
create
this reflexive relationship between the
light of pure Consciousness and its
self-reflexive power is known as spanda
a vibration or pulsation
it's important again here to remind
ourselves that this is not an actual
Duality there's no difference between
Shiva and Shakti in reality between pure
Consciousness and its power Shiva
remains one and unchanging you can kind
of imagine it like when you look at one
of those pictures that can be like
either a dog or a rabbit depending on
how you look at the picture it's the
same picture but depending on how you
look at it it appears as a different
thing so this Duality this artificial
Duality between Shiva and Shakti can be
seen as in this kind of same way
this Duality is only in appearance
depending on how we look at it but
really it's the same reality that's
contemplating itself abhinavagupta
points out that while the Supreme Lord
manifests movement and is dynamic that
doesn't mean at all that there is an
actual change or movement within the
reality of Shiva he is one with all
things including with the changing and
moving diversity of the world but he
never actually changes or or
or becomes anything other than the
Oneness of itself in spite of all these
things he somehow Still Remains one and
unchanged quote by a vibration we mean
subtle movement it is subtle in the
sense that although it moves not it
manifests motion
the light of Consciousness is not at all
separate from manifestation yet it
appears to be so
thus that which is immobile associated
with a variety of manifestation
manifests as movement
this Dynamic vibration has significant
metaphysical consequences when he
contemplates himself and through his
Free Will Shiva sort of conceals his
absolute nature he becomes Limited in a
sense
the result is the manifestation in
consciousness of the world of
Multiplicity as an appearance of the
absolute and successive limited forms to
its own self indeed the Kashmir shivites
use the metaphor of a mirror to explain
this calling it the doctrine of
pratibimbawada or reflection the
universe as we know it is like the
reflection in a mirror a reflection of
infinite absolute Consciousness in
fleeting limited forms in a mirror that
is also identical to that absolute in
other words it is the limited appearance
of Shiva in Shiva through an awareness
that is Shiva lakshman Jewel writes
quote the universe therefore is
reflected in the mirror of Consciousness
not in the organs during the five gross
elements these are merely tatvas and
cannot reflect anything
the real reflector is consciousness
in Consciousness however you see only
the reflected thing and not the object
that is reflected
that which is reflected is in fact
swatantria Shiva or shiva's free will
this whole universe is the reflection of
svatantria in God consciousness
the only part of this mirror metaphor
that doesn't work is the fact that in a
real mirror there is an outer object
that is reflected in the mirror and this
is obviously not the case here there is
no outer object what is reflected in the
mirror where the mirror is consciousness
and the thing that is mirrored the
object that is being mirrored is
consciousness itself it's the mirror
itself and what we see in the mirror is
the limited forms
or appearances of Consciousness in the
mirror of Consciousness reflecting
Consciousness itself it is the
self-knowledge of the self Mark
deskowsky writes quote the universe is
the wonderful variety of shiva's nature
created by him when he reflects on
himself and thinks I am diverse Shiva
contemplates none other than himself
whether he knows himself as the
multiplicity of things or as their
undivided source
all the multiplicity of the world is
real completely real if we were to say
that it's unreal in any way even in its
diversity as the vedant would say we
would be saying that God isn't real
Shiva is all there is and the world is
only this manifestation of Shiva to his
own awareness and through his active
power which is Shakti but while this
multiplicity is real it is also simply
the Oneness of the Supreme contemplating
itself so its non-duality is never
compromised again abhinava Gupta says
quote
everything that exists resides within
the Blessed Lord bairava
whatever appears within our hearts or
leaves the point of our tongue resides I
say in parameshwara who is not limited
by time is one with Consciousness and is
perpetually United with all the powers
he constitutes a Unity which coexists
without contradiction where the hundreds
of creations and dissolutions which are
manifested by his contraction and
expansion and that is by means of these
that he expresses his freedom
this reality of Shiva therefore has
neither beginning nor end and is
Luminous with its own light
its Essence is a complete Freedom which
consists in perfect Independence
determined by the fullness of all things
within itself it Embraces all principles
which are in effect identical with it
and Mark discovsky summarizes it really
nicely in his book called the doctrine
of vibration by saying quote Unity Is
Not Mere negation of Distinction but the
absence of difference in diversity
this is a doctrine of reality which is
simultaneously deceptively simple but
also very complex
Shiva is everything but it's not a
simple or crude pantheism Shiva is also
completely Transcendent at the same time
in his pure nature quote we cannot
simply consider Shiva to be the sum
total of the entire manifest reality he
is more than that infinitely more
however his condition of surpassing his
own manifestation does not in any way
cause him to be separate from that
manifestation
and just as the world comes to be
through this process of Shiva concealing
himself it also always goes back and
comes back to resting in the Oneness of
the Supreme a movement of going out and
returning back although this movement of
course takes place within itself Shakti
is a very important concept to Kashmir
shaibism as we've already seen it is the
power of Shiva the part that is
self-reflexive and which manifests the
universe all of the world is Shakti in a
direct sense all that we see around us
is the activity of Shakti where Shiva
sort of remains hidden in the darkness
of the unfathomable unchanging
consciousness Shakti the goddess or
divine feminine is in a constant
pulsating Act of love with Shiva when
Shakti becomes separated so to say from
Shiva the world comes to be as the
self-reflexiveness of Consciousness
whereas when the two unite again the
world returns to nothingness in the
Oneness of the absolute we could go on
all day about the intricacies of this
philosophical system but these are the
basic features of the metaphysics of
Kashmir shaivism a strict non-dualism
that in order to maintain that
non-dualism involves a view of the
Divine as both unity and diversity as
both being Transcendent and unchanging
and simultaneously Dynamic and active
quote creation is to make that which
shines within externally manifest while
it still preserves its original internal
nature therefore the object must be made
manifest by that in relation to which it
is said to be internal and which makes
the internal externally manifest
so this leads us to the Practical
aspects of this tradition which are as
we said in the beginning maybe the most
important part this is after all the
tradition that is in primarily
interested in spiritual practices and
and sort of reaching Liberation right
the individual person being freed from
the the wheel of samsara about preaching
Liberation as is very common across all
of indic religions or indic religious
Traditions these theoretical or
philosophical aspects that we've talked
about basically only serve as the
tapestry or the theoretical explanation
for the experiences and practices that
are at the core of this tradition so
what is actually the goal for the
non-dual shivite well as the school of
recognition indicates it is to realize
or recognize one's identity with the
Supreme Lord to realize that oneself and
everything in reality are simply the
absolute self of Shiva it is to
recognize that we all are Shiva and that
there is nothing else in a sense it is
to sort of say Unite with God but in
reality there is no uniting of course
because Shiva can't Unite with himself
rather the emphasis is on realizing or
recognizing that we already are unified
with or identical with Shiva indeed in
the opening prayer to his commentary on
the bhagavad-gita abhinava Gupta says
quote stating briefly Moksha is merging
with the Lord Shiva with whom everything
is identical whose nature is Purity who
is the doer of all actions omniscient
free from desire and permanently
manifest
and this is done in slightly different
ways than in other Traditions the
affirmative nature of the system means
that there isn't as much focus on
renunciation and world negating
the world isn't an illusion it's not
Maya in the sense that the vedantans
believe at least the advice of advantage
Maya is the creative power and will of
Shiva which creates a real world of
Multiplicity
not only that but the world in all its
diversity is literally Shiva or Shakti
not just in the sense that Shiva is its
underlying true reality which hides
beneath the illusion of Multiplicity but
as that multiplicity too
we aren't to turn away from the world
and from the senses but instead to use
them to reach Enlightenment the shivites
do affirm a kind of asceticism for sure
this isn't Hedonism we are still to turn
away from the false understanding of the
things of the world as self-existing and
independent and to instead see them as
identical with Shiva quote take one
particle of anything which exists in
this world in that one particle there is
to be realized the totality of the whole
universe the totality of energy is found
in one particle
everything is full of one thing and one
thing is full of all things
this is where we see adherence of this
tradition not necessarily being
renunciant monks like what is common in
other Hindu schools instead the Shia
bites often had families and lived a
regular householder's life with a job
Etc the pleasures of the senses whether
that be food beautiful music or theater
scents or even sex none of it isn't
heavily bad or to be avoided instead one
should enjoy the sense experiences to
the fullest but to do this means to not
enjoy them for themselves as most
regular people do instead all sense
experience and enjoyment should only be
used as a way to reach God to see them
as the reflections of God and with the
awareness of their metaphysical role
which can help us on the path to
enlightenment
this is important the shivites are not
hedonists and certainly practice
rigorous spirituality where one does not
blindly follow one's lusts or desires
but it does involve a more affirmative
look at the body and its experiences of
the world of Multiplicity as something
potentially good as an experience of the
activity of Shakti or the manifestation
of the Supreme self and Consciousness
and only if it is pursued and understood
in such a way is it truly beneficial
one can easily get lost in these
sensible if one doesn't understand it
properly but if one realizes that one's
own self is not the limited physical
body and mind but infinite Consciousness
itself then the body becomes a temple a
place where through the Divine senses
one can directly experience the
pulsation of spanda or of Shakti as it
manifests the absolute the most
influential figure in the philosophical
School of recognition with paladeva
writes quote how wonderful is it that
although only one sound that is shiva's
name is always on the tips of their
tongues yet his devotees can taste the
ineffable relish of all the objects of
the senses
as far as the ritual practices that the
Kashmir shivites actually took part in
this is a complicated topic as we said
earlier this is essentially a tantric
tradition right this belongs to the
larger lineage of Tantra and so when we
look at the practices of Kashmir
shaivism they are often the same or very
closely related to those same practices
within the tradition the larger
tradition of Tantra we've dedicated a
full episode to Tanta in particular
which you can advise if you want to know
more or go more deeply into those
particular practices and one such aspect
we have just talked about namely the the
the employment of sense experience and
the body as a as a way to reach
Enlightenment rather than something to
be completely shunned or turned away
from one can use the body and and the
experiences of the of this of the of the
senses even
feelings of lust and such feelings one
can use those to experience the
pulsation of Consciousness the the
so-called spanda right of Shiva and that
can be a vessel to Enlightenment so this
emphasis on the body this more more
positive look at the body and the senses
is one aspect and many practices and
rituals involving the senses and the
body rather than those that neglect the
body like in many other yogic tradition
for instance but in general it's
somewhat difficult to talk about the
actual practices of this tradition
because it is one that is essentially
esoteric or initiatory in order to take
part in the tradition you need to be
initiated by a teacher a guru who will
then impart the teachings and practices
to you
specifics can vary depending on the
person and because it is esoteric it
isn't really something that is spoken
about publicly now you can find out
about a lot of these practices through
books and such esotericism is rarely
truly esoteric these days but still
there is a level of secrecy at the core
here which prevents us from truly
knowing some of the details but in
general just like in Tantra at large
tarika Shiva practice involves different
forms of meditation there is often talk
about a one-pointed or single-pointed
meditation which can mean a form of
meditation where one literally fixes
one's Gaze on a single point or more
generally as fixing one's mind on a
particular concept or visualization
the guru will teach different techniques
of meditation which might involve things
like breath control and visualization
techniques
this is another key aspect of Tantra the
practice of visualization as a means to
reach higher spiritual States if you've
ever seen the beautiful and complex
mandalas often associated with Tibetan
Buddhism for example then you have
encountered an example of this mandalas
are often images used precisely as a
help or Aid in these visualization
practices and can involve different gods
or Divine worlds and scenes with
Incredible depth that is meant to be
sort of trans inducing basically
similarly another important key feature
of this tradition are of course mantras
phrases or words usually given
specifically by a guru to the initiate
that are chanted and often during
meditation
the most famous Mantra sound is probably
the OM which often comes to represent
the Brahman or Divine as a whole and as
an underlying sound or vibration from
which the whole universe emerges another
common Mantra in the shaibai tradition
in particular is om namah shivaya but
there are many different mantras and
variants that can be assigned by a guru
indeed when talking about practice in
the Tantra loka abhinabagupta divides it
into four different levels or means to
realization the no means anupaya the
Divine means
the empowered means shaktopaya and the
individual means
the first three of these are exclusively
internal practices levels on which
Consciousness recognizes and
contemplates itself in different modes
it is only in the lowest level the
individual means that actual physical
spiritual practices are apart a kind of
yoga in other words
closest student comments on this by
listing a few of these core practices of
shaiba Tantra yoga which is different in
many ways from the classic yoga of
patanjali he mentions posture Asana
regulation of the breath pranayama
focusing of attention darana meditation
dhyana and contemplation samadhi these
individual means in turn lead to the
person achieving the higher means she
reaches the empowered means which are
all internal from this one reaches the
Divine means and finally the no means
which is when one is simply non-distinct
from the reality of Shiva and simply
experiences infinite Consciousness as
that Consciousness itself
Shakti is often seen as the door Toshiba
it is through Shakti the creative power
that we eventually reach Shiva and since
Shakti is that power that is manifested
everywhere we experience Shakti through
the body and the senses hence aesthetic
experiences such as listening to music
can be a form of spiritual practice as
well as more controversial things such
as rituals involving sex
indeed Tantra is today in the west
primarily and wrongly associated with
sex
as we explored in our previous video
this is often a grave misreading or
misunderstood aspect of this tradition
as I hope you have seen Tantra is so
much more than that
but it is true that sexual rituals while
not that common or Central have played a
part because the sexual act represents
the union and relationship between Shiva
and Shakti the two primary aspects of
supreme Consciousness itself one can use
that profoundly powerful Central
experience of sex as a tool for
enlightenment through a mirroring of the
essential pulsation of reality itself in
a kind of microcosmic form when the two
practitioners are engaging in a ritual
Act of sex they are mirroring the sexual
act of Shiva and Shakti the the basic
pulsation movements of reality itself in
any case this is only one of a number of
different practices involved in Tantra
when Kashmir shaivism in particular and
it should not be over emphasized the way
it has been so often it still is very
much so in the Western World when
talking about the topic of Tantra all of
these practices whether they be mantras
or meditation or bodily practice of
course have a single purpose of becoming
one with the infinite consciousness of
Shiva to merge one's individual
Consciousness to the absolute
shemaraja says quote the yogis who has
achieved a state of complete absorption
even when risen from meditation inwardly
vibrating like a drunkard and Blissful
inebriation from the after effects of
the nectar of contemplation
sees all things dissolving in the sky of
Consciousness like a cloud in the Autumn
sky
he plunges repeatedly within himself and
becomes aware of his identity with
Consciousness by the practice of
introverted contemplation
thus even when he is said to have risen
from absorption he is one with his
experience of it
at this point one becomes what one
already was one becomes aware of the
all-encompassing nature of Shiva whose
totality includes all manifestation and
diversity in a single Dynamic Oneness
the Supreme Consciousness from which
through which and in which all of
reality unfolds this has obviously been
just a very short introduction to an
incredibly complicated topic the
tradition of tarika shaivism or Kashmir
shaivism stretches back for Millennia
and has been incredibly influential
especially on the religions and
philosophies of India it has still
survived up until this very day with
practitioners all around the world
taking part in its teachings and
practices it also once again points the
incredible diversity of what we refer to
as Hinduism or sanatana Dharma while
eduita vedanta is definitely the most
famous example of a non-dualistic school
within that religion Kashmir shaivism is
another example of a similar philosophy
that is simultaneously different in some
significant ways and is a lot to offer
in terms of its teachings
it offers some profound ideas about the
nature of reality and produce some of
the greatest thinkers in the history of
the world such as abhinava Gupta
if you want to dive deeper into the
topic than there is as always a list of
sources and recommended readings in the
description which I highly recommend
that you check out sadly there isn't as
much written on Kashmir shaivism as one
would maybe hope at least not compared
with other philosophical schools in
Hinduism like vedanta for example but
there are some essential texts and
articles that you can advise all of
which again are in the description for
now I'm going to leave it at that but be
sure that Kashmir shaivism and its many
representatives are going to show up
again in the future in future episodes
on this channel if you want more content
like this about these topics then feel
free also to subscribe to the channel
and give the video a like and maybe even
a comment and let me know what you think
and maybe suggestions for future
episodes for example as always I would
like to thank my patrons so so much for
their continuing support I wouldn't be
able to do any of this without you guys
and sometimes I like to shout out some
of the new arrivals on my patreon team
so here are a few new names
Dolly Christopher all coins flement Brax
and Sam thank you all so so much for the
support
patreon is really the best way to
support this channel it helps me uh
gather the the the books for research it
helps pay for video editing softwares
and and and all the all the stuff that I
need to make these videos as good as
possible so I'm truly humbled and
eternally grateful to all of you for
supporting this Channel and my work a
work of bringing free content and
educational content on the world's
different religious and philosophical
traditions which is something that I am
incredibly passionate about and which it
seems there is a lot of you out there
who are passionate about it as well and
so it really is all thanks to you guys
all of my patrons and all the viewers
out there so thank you so much if anyone
else wants to become a patron and
support this channel that would of
course be highly appreciated so I'm
Gonna Leave links to all that stuff in
the description and probably also not
pinned comments you can check it out
there I hope you learned something today
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you